it is a busy news day on this tuesday
because it's also primary day and we
have live team coverage throughout the
night for you kirsten joyce is standing
by but first we begin with christian
casares he's at the county election
department near cheyenne and mlk with an
update now christian on voter turnout
that's right brian and denise let me
tell you this is basically the calm
before the storm as it normally tends to
happen on election day but let me step
here out of the way so you can get a
better picture as you mentioned we are
outside the clark county election center
office here in north las vegas officials
here tell me there have been a steady
flow in traffic nevadans can drop off
their ballots at this location now
county officials have set up 125 voting
locations to help make this process easy
for all residents now in about four
hours when the polls close crews will
pack up everything the machines and
everything will be turned into this
facility here in north las vegas this is
where the votes will be counted tonight
where the first results will be the
mail-in ballots and early voting no word
yet on what time that will happen but of
course we will be on top of that
information more than 68 thousand clark
county residents have casted their
ballots during the early voting period
according to county officials which that
period wrapped up on friday now many
residents telling us today the economy
is what dr is was basically driving them
to the polls they want to be part of the
change and they hope that their vote
today will help now another important
thing to remember if you decide to vote
by mail don't forget to sign your ballot
officials here tell me
the vote won't be counted if there is no
signature of course that signature has
to match what is on file when you
register to vote so of course
long night he's still ahead and a lot of
work still to be done here at this
location but for now this is the latest
from north las vegas let's send things
over to my colleague kirsten joyce who
is down at the galleria mall over in
henderson kirsten